bonsoir didier maïsto merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une
réaction après les propos de gérald
darmanin vous qui avez couvert beaucoup
de manifestations d gilet jaune et vous
en avez beaucoup parlé ici aussi sur ce
plateau
oui une réaction l état figé cette
réaction
en réalité qu'est ce qui se passe toutes
les personnes qui comme moi ont couvert
un certain nombre de manifestations sur
le terrain savent ce qu'il ya derrière
cette proposition de loi qui en fait un
projet de loi une proposition de loi
déguisé qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière la
volonté d'avoir une information
exfiltré purifier complètement neutre et
en tout cas toujours du côté de
l'exécutif parce que qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé sur le terrain à l'occasion
notamment de gilets jaunes et à leur
suite de toutes les manifestations de
fonctionnaires d'avocats un nouveau
métier en quelque sorte est né sous nos
yeux des street reporters comme on les a
appelés des gens qui ont pris leur
téléphone portable des jeunes
journalistes des gens qui n'allaient pas
forcément une carte de presse et qui de
l'intérieur ont montré ce qu'il se
passait dans le schéma des maintien de
l'ordre qui sont complètement à revoir
je rappelle quand même que il y a eu 30
éborgné quatre morts cinq mains
arrachées des arrestations arbitraires
mille gilet jaune en prison c'est une
première depuis la libération et nous
avons basculé dans une autre forme de
régime
il y avait un péché originel de ce
régime je l'avais dit avant l'élection
nous en souvenez des manuels macron il
ya une fascination pour l'ordre et la
sécurité au sens italien du terme au
sens latin fashi les fâche les faisceaux
italien de l'ict heures et donc il ya
cette fascination pour l'ordre et la
sécurité la sécurité
un journaliste
n'a pas être protégé un journaliste n'a
pas à être encadrés
un journaliste n'a pas à prendre ses
ordres auprès d'un exécutif un
journaliste a besoin que d'une seule
chose de liberté ça veut dire clairement
que selon l'amendement d'ailleurs qu'a
annoncé gérald darmanin déposé sur la
loi de sécurité on pourra empêcher
maintenant de films et on pourrait être
empêchés de filmer les policiers sur le
terrain
clairement mais c'est mais c'est une
évidence quand il y a eu et il ya deux
jours la mobilisation devant l'assemblée
nationale nous avons eu en quelque sorte
un avertissement une avant qu'une
avant-première une voyons ici les images
la loi n'est pas encore votée que vous
avez déjà des policiers qui molestent
qui violente
on a vu cette jeune anna panthères à
nice news qui a été embarqué une jeune
photoreporter de 18 ans qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait elle faisait rien de mal
elle faisait juste sans métier
donc si comme le dit le ministre de
l'intérieur on peut être évacués après
sommation il le dit lui-même il n'y aura
pas d'exception
ça veut dire qu'on ne pourra pas comme
je lé fais comme d'autres l'ont fait
comme beaucoup de journalistes de rtl
ont fait être au coeur de l'événement
pour pouvoir décrypter ce qui se passe
donc là on va se contenter de
journalistes de préfecture accrédités
bien plan-plan je les ai vus mois ces
journalistes je les ai vus vous savez
comment ça s'est passé j'ai souvent
dénoncés ils arrivent le matin à 9
heures ils plantent les caméras en
général en haut des immeubles ils vont
faire leurs petites emplettes
les manifestations se déroulent y
reviennent à 17 heures et ils disent
assez violent il ya des black blocks il
ya des poubelles qui brûlent
mais nous qui étions sur le terrain nous
avons documenté tout ça nous avons
montré tout ça
si nous n'étions pas là il n'y aurait
pas eu d'affairé nana il n'y aurait pas
eu de toutes ces affaires de policiers
et hyper violents qui se sont
transformés en ça s'est transformé en
bataille de rues à coups de poing à coup
de tête
combien de gens étaient éborgné nous
avons pu documenter ce qui est arrivé à
girone rodrigues il n'était bien
pacifique sous la bastille en train de
faire son live et de dire les jeunes eux
repliés vous il ya des black blocks
on se replie république c'est trop
dangereux et là tout de suite poum le
bloc caractéristiques du lb d alors
l'igpn qui est littéralement une farce
avait dit que c'était n'est ce pas un
caoutchouc d'une grenade plus
intelligent que les autres qui avait
sauté sur la chaussée et qui manque de
sens et est allée se loger dans l'oeil
nous avons séquence par séquence toutes
les personnes qui étions là qui avons
filmé nous avons démonté cette feuille
que news
nous avons pu démontrer que un policier
était posté sur la droite et avec une
personne cliente ne vise pas la tête ne
vise pas la tête nous avons pu démontrer
que la grenade avait bien été lancée au
sol et qu'elle avait explosé avant et
non pas comme il a été dit au moment où
elle a touché
jérôme andriès et donc que veut ce
gouvernement bien sûr comme il est en
grande difficulté
premièrement et deuxièmement qu'il a une
fascination pour l'ordre et la cie et la
sécurité il veut exfiltrer ses mauvais
journalistes qui font un travail de
terrain pour avoir des journalistes
accrédités avait d'ailleurs lui le garde
des sceaux semble avoir conscience du
problème et il essaye de trouver la
parade
il a proposé de changer en réalité le
code de procédure pénale pour faire en
sorte que toute personne qui n'est pas
journaliste puisse être convoqué en
comparution immédiate si elle est
accusée de diffuser la haine en ligne en
clair faire sortir le nom journalistes
de la loi de 1881 votre réaction
écoutez moi je suis je me méfie
beaucoup quand un gouvernement veut
modifier une loi qui fonctionne cette
loi de 1881
elle fonctionne elle a été je vais pas
rappeler tout l'historique elle a été
conquise de haute lutte
et justement au départ pour interdire
pour mettre en une barrière étanche
entre les pouvoirs de l'argent entre les
pouvoirs politique et la profession de
journaliste nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
moment nous n'avons pas besoin de
nouvelles lois qu'on nous foute la paix
qu'on nous laisse travailler en liberté
nous n'avons pas besoin dead nous avons
besoin d'air nous avons besoin d'oxygène
et pas de gaz lacrymogènes nous avons
besoin de liberté et pas d'injonction
voilà quelle est la vérité
donc est ce que les politiciens la
politique vous pas nier les journalistes
fassent leur métier vous parler de
liberté ça ressemble un petit peu un
devoir de philo de terminale mais
aujourd'hui est ce qu on en est réduit
finalement choisir entre la sécurité
notamment aussi celle des policiers
parce qu'il ya eu aussi des blessés du
côté des policiers et la liberté
pas du tout j'entends souvent que la
première des libertés c'est la sécurité
moi je dirais que la première des
sécurités c'est la liberté
et quant aux policiers qui sont soit
disant menacés sur les réseaux sociaux
jeune je ne le nie pas il faut un
travail difficile et je mets pas tout le
monde dans le même panier
loin s'en faut mais il ya déjà une loi
qui existe c'est un mensonge de dire que
cette loi est là pour protéger les
policiers qui sont qui seraient jetés en
pâture comme ça sur les réseaux sociaux
je prends un seul exemple il ya eu une
une jeune fille de 2 21 ans une
étudiante qui s'était mis en tête de
photographier les policiers de les
suivre de les poursuivre dans les
pourchasser à la fédé portrait de donner
leurs coordonnées et les afficher sur
les réseaux sociaux
elle a pris dix sept mois de prison
donc la loi existe c'est pas la peine
sur fois sous l'émotion
premièrement sous l'émotion deuxièmement
sous la difficulté et troisièmement il
faut bien un jour le dire et ce soir je
le dis la police s'est laissée
complètement noyautée par des syndicats
extrêmement dur extrêmement politisé des
syndicats extrémistes je vous invite à
lire les tweets d'alliance ont dû du
syndicat synergie il syndicat des
commissaires qui appelle littéralement à
la guerre civile et qui font des
partitions dans la population
déjà on peut se poser la question de
savoir si le seul le syndicalisme est
compatible avec la profession la mission
de policiers admettant acceptons-en
l'auguré très bien ils ont le droit ce
sont des agents de l'état de faire
avancer leur carrière de défendre leurs
droits etc
moi je je je pense qu'il faudrait bien
réfléchir si ce type d'agent peut être
syndiqués mais acceptons le fait qu'ils
soient syndiqués mais qu'ils fassent les
tournées de plateaux de télé pour avoir
des discours de haine des discours de
haine
moi j'ai les ai vus manifester quand il
était à république quand il était à
bastille se cachant l'oeil quand ils
passaient devant jérôme rodrigues est-ce
que c'est acceptable cela en république
française
nous sommes les français sont attachés
ne sommes pas des dangereux anarchistes
des nihilistes absolue nous sommes
attachés à une police républicaine
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
la police est nécessaire mais que cette
police soit républicaine et qu'elle se
comporte correctement et tout se passera
mieux
dernier élément en parle souvent de
l'article 24
effectivement la pousse de
l'impossibilité pour les journalistes de
diffuser des images qui porterait
atteinte à l'intégrité physique et
morale des policiers avec une espèce de
délire comme ça d'intentionnalité
confiée au juge qui devra estimer
après avoir lu jung et freud et lacan
s'il y avait bien un délit d'intention
intentionnelle de faire mal aux
policiers article 24 mai
en symétrie il y à l'article 21 qui
permet aux policiers et compris par
drones de capter les images des citoyens
en train de manifester on sait pas où
vont finir ces images on sait pas qui
les conservera on sait pas moi je n'ai
pas envie d'être filmé dans ma vie
privée et et même si je manifeste
et d'ailleurs la défenseure des droits
très courageusement et ix a été très peu
souligné dans la poêle ce après à la
suite de jacques toubon a émis un avis
très critiques très sévères mais aussi
l'onu mais aussi la ligue des droits de
l'homme mais aussi 40 sociétés de
rédacteurs
nous sommes en train de basculer dans un
régime qui ne dit pas son nom et je vous
ai parlé des faisceaux je ne vais pas
faire de grands mots vous regarderez
l'étymologie du mot faisceau c'est une
première c'est un recul insupportable
des libertés en france et moins je vous
l'annoncé ce soir
quoi qu'il se passe je continuerai à
filmer et je continuerai à diffuser
parce que je suis dans le pays de la
liberté liberté j'écris ton nom
voilà merci didier maïsto d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france